but
as ever
there is a sensible middle ground
we should not be ideological about this
we should be pragmatic
it is possible to both tax extraordinary
profits fairly
and incentivize investment
and so like previous governments
including conservative ones we will
introduce a temporary targeted energy
profits levy but
we have built into the new levy
but
we have built into the new levy
but we have built into the new levy
a new investment allowance similar to
the super deduction
that means
that means companies will have a new and
significant incentive to reinvest their
profits
the new levy will be charged on profits
of oil and gas companies at a rate of 25
percent it will be temporary and when
oil and gas prices return to
historically more normal levels the levy
will be phased out with a sunset clause
written into the legislation
and crucially and crucially
with our new investment allowance
we are nearly doubling the overall
investment relief for oil and gas
companies
that means for every pound a company
invests
they'll get back 90 percent in tax
relief
so the more a company invests the less
tax they will pay
first people on the lowest incomes
over 8 million households already have
incomes low enough for the state to be
supporting their cost of living through
the welfare system
they could be temporarily unemployed and
looking for work
unable to work because of long-term
sickness a disability
or on low pay and using benefits to top
up their wages
right now
they face incredibly difficult choices
so i can announce today
we will send directly to around 8
million of the lowest income households
a one-off cost of living payment of
650 pounds
[Applause]
support worth over 5 billion pounds to
give vulnerable people certainty
that we are standing by them at this
challenging time